what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna do two parter
for Brooklyn nine nine today 10 and 11.
uh I'm excited John how are you I am so
excited already ladies and gently know
what to do leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated you know
how this goes let's just go into action
quick reminder of the rules 40 limit no
perishable items and no homemade massage
coupons I would like a 40 gift card to
any restaurant that serves nachos I
don't have you Peralta for the brilliant
mind of detective Jacob Sherlock Peralta
it's quite simply
Elementary Amy made a face I only
recognized from our bedroom which means
that she has Captain halt Charles has
Terry his eyes keep shifting over to him
he has Hitchcock Rosa didn't draw a name
nor did she put one in she doesn't want
to participate never do
Charles I did get Charlotte Scully has
Amy he's holding his paper named side
out oh he's good and I have Scully which
means Captain Hook isn't that gift card
Daddy loves nachos should we draw the
names again and leave Jake out yeah
oh
it's a good detective work why would you
leave Jake out it's messed up okay quick
update on the Warren Street break and
security cameras caught a picture of the
suspect we got a hot purple alert
oh damn oh yeah bring that guy to
Justice we all would but unfortunately
police cornered him and he shot himself
in the face
oh boy all right thank you for that
cheese
anything else uh yes
something I'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go I'm bisexual I'm bisexual I
will now field one minute and zero
seconds of questions pertaining to this
go Amy how long have you known it's in
seventh grade Zach Morris is hot and
then I thought Lisa Turtle also hot
what made you decide to tell us now
Charles found out on the road trip and I
was positive he was not going to be able
to keep the secret for much longer bye
Rosa
I mean not bye but bye I mean
only having sex with men just banging
dudes left and right I just stopped
saying bye all together so are you
seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes I am you know
Anne Heche I do
we have time for one more question nope
absolutely not we're done
smart he was not tasteful
[Laughter]
I've been trying to file a warrant
request for 45 minutes and the stupid
server keeps timing out nothing's
loading it's all pinwheels because
Rosa's bisexual oh no so how'd your
parents take it I haven't told them yet
really I mean of course you don't have
to but so I don't know how I would say
something like that especially to my dad
he's super traditional I'm afraid this
would just mess everything up
we've been having so much fun lately
[Music]
oh my
Danny
Trejo filed for bankruptcy is he really
I'm bisexual but I'm still your daughter
I'm still the same person that I've
always been and who I love will never
change that and I don't want to hide Who
I Am anymore
I am bi that was and I know this may
come as
all right good luck thanks
that's good
treasure
hey guys watching a video no buffering
they got all the bars Captain all the
bars keep it together you must be
Raymond Holtz oh yeah whoa no germs
cheers
unbeef unfortunately broad options he's
just not scared of us right but there is
one person who scares everyone
way we were just talking about this I
like I sort of straight splained how to
come out to you no it was a good
practice
my parents that's awesome what are you
gonna do it five minutes what yeah
[Music]
Jesus Christ
neither did I what a fun surprise that
none of us were remotely prepared for
Rosa right you seem nervous why global
warming anyways I'm gonna head to the
bathroom for the duration of one
conversation no uh guys I have something
I need to tell you oh geez don't worry
we know what's happening you and Jake
are dating that's why you were nervous
first of all that's insane we've only
met once and we totally hit it off we
talked about soccer I called it football
oh I see what happens
cyber is hogging our internet and we
can't get them to stop sorry I can't
that's Precinct business and your
maternity leave is over in two weeks Amy
volume okay volume
yeah
we should pretend to be a couple for
tonight and then I'll tell them in a few
weeks that we broke up hands off my butt
it's not gonna be a problem well you say
that now but you're about to enter the
Jake Peralta boyfriend experience it can
be quite intoxicating oh man these are
my Friday jeans
[Laughter]
we need to woo them with the
international language of friendship
poor oh I'll take it to them it's all
dudes down there and I'm not above using
little flirtation to get what I want was
that a wink you tell me
all right
hello boys
[Music]
I arranged my contact out I don't know
it's still there oh God it's behind my
eyes I've been there I was hoping we
could start fresh so we got you this
decent great now that you've accepted
our meat pile perhaps you'll help us
restore it
I can definitely help with that how many
kbps's are you looking for Manny yeah
that's not an answer I need an exact
number
100. ten thousand too many four okay bro
I'll give you four kilobytes of Internet
you're making a fool yourself
nah you're the fool oh I don't even
know who you are but I know who you are
Devin you tell everyone you got a degree
from Stanford but you really went to
Stamford an online college based in
Arkansas oh
and you spend a third of your salary on
tropical fish and Aquaria his real
name's Clarence
I just been crazy about her forever and
then one day I picked up my battered old
guitar and I sang her a song
sing the song Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa Rosa
Rosa Rosa
oh girl and she was showing off a ring
wow you gotta really look at that
picture huh what's going on Jake and
Emmy are engaged that's okay what you
understand
love is complicated why would he Jesus
Christ you were so nervous we were
worried you were gonna tell us you were
gay so you would rather me be some
dude's mistress than be in a loving
relationship with a woman Jake and I
aren't dating your worst fears are real
I'm not straight I'm bisexual screw this
I'm out of here uh the bill
hey so I ran after you last night but I
lost you in the subway it's in a cab
home really well then I definitely
terrified some randomly
text me last night
don't worry about dinner see you at game
night nice I told them by and they still
invited me to game night enjoy gaming
actually they want you to come to make
up for how awkward dinner was oh
fantastic I'm still involved
beautiful delivery most importantly make
your avatars gifts I was thinking more
like a pizza party when you come back in
two weeks oh yeah so here's the thing
I'm not coming back what listen I have a
daughter now when she grows up I want to
be doing something that makes her proud
I'm running a sports league for other
people's pets oh well Gina as your
index lover I fully support your dreams
but do you really want to leave my mind
is made up and so this is Gina linetti's
last grand exit from the nine nine it's
really happening
I don't know
do you think that's the last time we'll
ever see her oh no
bye Gina
[Music]
it's the first time we've seen beyond
the Gina curtain we want you to know
we're not upset great I'm upset either
because you still like men so you can
still get married and have a child I can
do those things with either a man or a
woman yes or it will be a man because
this is just a phase Jesus
so since you're not coming back for you
all your stuff blackmail files you've
been keeping on all of us I'm not a
blackmailer if you tell anyone I am I
will release your secrets
you're indispensable we're really gonna
miss you and I loved the 99 it feels
like it's time for me to like build
something of my own Oprah Winfrey Lex
Luthor is Superman villain he built an
Empire didn't he it really did and he
helps the Justice League sometimes two
women they're holding hands uh friends
oh um
in infinitely there's no such thing as
being bisexual I'm attracted to both men
and women I didn't want to tell you
because I was afraid you were going to
react exactly like you are that you
accept me for who I am okay let's go
hilarious
it's weird My Dad's here hey do you mind
staying out here with me to talk to him
um yes of course whatever you need your
face no man you've done enough get out
of here oh thank God
your good friend Jacob hello
thank you
I want you to be able to tell me
everything I promise you all understand
I'm trying I want you to know that I
accept you for who you are and I love
you very very much don't judge
have you been on any dates with women
yet Dad we didn't talk about my dating
life before we don't need to talk about
it now good good you're right so where's
mom mom needs a little more time
she's not the celebrity guest yes yes
also if you must knock on my door limit
yourself to two wraps if I wanted to
hear a name pounding take a grocery
stomp we had to hire someone to replace
you Gina because you quit come back baby
Captain Holt said to give me a five
percent raise if I came back and he's
letting me sit at my desk and work on my
side business one day a week we never
had that conversation we just did baby
see you man bangs man bangs welcome back
lynetti thanks man
all right look see you now come on let's
just ask now admit it was you guys
actually even cried a little bit after
you left my apartment what I had a baby
10 weeks ago I cried to a carpet cleaner
commercial yesterday Tina welcome back
it's great to see you what's everybody
doing tonight nothing why there's
something we all need to do game night
yes
what's going on Family Game Night don't
worry I brought twister
don't worry
oh that's sweet another lifetime you and
I would have made a hot ass couple
agreed agreed yes you should be very
proud of yourself I know things aren't
exactly where you want to be right now
but uh I promise you they will approve
how could you possibly understand holes
seriously only have two wine glasses
you're gonna need to get some more
because there's a lot of us here roads
have I broke both of your wine glasses
in your fridge door in your bathroom
[Laughter]
next episode starting ah thank you
Margaret you're welcome Raymond oh no
that's right remember how I saved the
detectives from prison in exchange for a
fit yes what do you want from me
I am not giving Seamus Murphy that
permit is a cover for something criminal
a robbery a murder or something worse
loopholes are the best remember that
time when Pancake Palace had that all
you can eat deal but they didn't set a
time limit
as always I'll be using the main hole or
no hole he just said whole way too much
sir and that's coming from Charles yes
that's concerning I think you know
someone Jake unbelievable
whole week of Pancakes I've had pancakes
in years oh no you should get some like
super protein fiber brand yes that's
what you want to Crave
um
cardboard sounds like a loophole nope we
found the main hole and it is open for
business oh gross yep go in the hole
first of all if we had developed a
Minority Report style pre-crime division
like I suggested we wouldn't be in this
Sheamus mess and it's not just
but secondly in The Godfather Don
Corleone had three sons Michael his
favorite Diane Keaton's husband okay
then there was sunny the hot head the
Lion King's brother-in-law Charles
you're being distracted no he's not he's
actually helping me to follow this
continue yes Diane Keaton's other
brother-in-law is Fredo the screw-up the
weak link and you think the Murphy's
ever afraid of every family does and in
this family his name is Kyle is he on
the road
if you don't figure out what his plan is
I don't give him that permit understood
yes sir all right go make contact with
Diane Keaton's brother-in-law Fredo it's
Fredo it's one of the most popular
movies of all time one best picture so
there's a Killian Murphy on that board
assignment hell yeah
[Music]
whoa it'll be quick we'll just go get
Murphy his permit and maybe grab a few
shots for the gram they have the
original permits for the 1939 World's
Fair no yes yeah no I mean no I don't
want to do this no yeah come on
it's very misleading Rosa so life is a
working mom you have to juggle the baby
the job your new business Terry juggling
isn't hard that's why the salary for
jugglers is so low we are small time
operators that just moved here from
Miami we slept with the same prostitute
no and she said he was the best she ever
had maybe and I should watch you to
learn back to know let's just not talk
about our sex life
[Music]
so you guys staring at me I don't know
we're just looking at the TV behind you
we left Finding Bigfoot it's our
favorite show should we hang out
sometime or am I being crazy you're not
being crazy Kyle
damn it
because we're so connected yes
[Music]
smooth
theorem recording studio where I lay
down my wraps and this is where the
magic happens it's where I practice
doing magic yeah
I accidentally ordered 100 lamps instead
of one they only give you like a six
month return window so you get it
totally man this place is huge we're
also involved in cream organized cream
cool cool hey just checking you guys
mean crime right yes okay good right go
on obviously I left the rolls there with
the keys in the ignition in case you
needed it but guess what happened
oh my God how did you guys know we're
just connected Kyle team Bigfoot team
Bigfoot you know anyone who's looking to
buy a lamp for really cheap I know a guy
oh Kyle yeah that's it that's how they
say it oh no bureaucracy is not stupid
it's elegant it's a beautiful puzzle
waiting to be cracked oh my God oh my
every form has its purpose it all fits
together and when the puzzle is solved
and you take a step back and see the big
picture shoot her in the head
this is just a puzzle and I can figure
it out to get an approve 1290 I need an
approved 1021j which I can't get without
an approved 1290 which I can't get
without an approved 10 20. oh my god
without an approved 12.90 which I can't
get without an approved 1021 J which I
can't get without how do you get job
experience she didn't know so much about
breast pumps Hitchcock well you should
know more about what's going on in your
Precinct there's no way she needs to be
pumping more than 20 minutes aside I
need my afternoon nap okay
it's helping I am having a brain baby
then push man push
you can do this you are so strong brain
kegels what if we could find that car
and have Kyle give it back to him but
how do we find that car we just did a
big sweep of Brooklyn chop shops maybe
Sheamus's car is one of them maybe it's
in the impound lot yes
1980 rolls White
okay put in my password
level that we Mortals can't even fathom
nice
ah Florence tinge
what uh it's a mistake they don't work
what but you wouldn't design a form that
literally can't be filed yeah I would I
did it all the time I just found out I'm
dyslexic good luck with all your uh
hoarding influence
Never Be Your Heroes
Avery dinner cereal oh my God what
instead of it being cold what if I heat
it up
unless is that just soup
I left my wallet at home I'm just gonna
turn around dude look
my favorite gamer just uploaded a new
vid and his mom
look behind that 1980 white Rolls-Royce
I wish the stupid car would move
isn't that your uncle's car oh my God
I found it I found my uncle's car
victory dance oh no wait stop Don't
Dance
I think I got hit
who is that guy violating uniform
conduct code 773 because the rules are
pointless because they're written by a
hoarder who doesn't care same here fight
the power ew oh this is every form sapo
has put out for a hundred years so you
ready for a kick-ass assignment
[Music]
yeah
yeah suit up oh no Kyle oh my rap career
I went somewhere different than I
thought I'm glad that you kept rapping
thanks this is the best dudes I've ever
known that's nice and hey guess what
it's like Action Bronson
party girls look I told you the forms
don't work you're not getting the permit
right how is this a part two no idea
there's nothing to do with the last one
okay but it says here that the form must
be submitted by a man I know it's a huge
bummer but also hi there I'd like to
humiliate some huskies and I'm in a
hurry
oh geez
juggling things is hard I feel like a
failure I feel like a Coulier you're not
a I got out I just realized I
told you it sucks and there's no
solution that's okay it's kind of nice
to hear this kind of thing from another
parent I don't even think Dave Coulier
juggles I Googled it he doesn't trip
Coulier you think that's the radio that
sounds like professional music to you
all music after Mahler sounds exactly
like that now how do we expect Kyle to
transfer
expensive bottle of whiskey to give to
his uncle as a gift the transmitter is
in the cork we plan for everything oh
Christ
jeez you didn't plan for everything you
forgot the idiot proof the bottle well
perhaps you want to idiot prove your
criticism because I got him a backup
bottle with a backup bug
good thing I had another one
[Music]
my rules I'm impressed
hey
welcome back to the family huh we have a
lot of catching up to do well done
nicely done this is planning on stealing
20 million dollars in bearer bonds from
an armored truck you changed the truck's
schedule so they hadn't picked up the
Bots yet empty Running on Empty he sings
that song Running surface okay so Terry
didn't like it Charles don't make me do
this Jake whatever Running on Empty
your block party is going well wasn't as
much fun as I hoped it would be but uh
you ever want to do business again my
door is always open well you should
close it lest you get mods today
uh what went wrong with the armored car
Heist he's pinning the blame on Kyle
everything was going great until he
suddenly reappeared out of the blue that
is the last time he screws over this
family
no
would do to him no they ran over a huge
pothole and then complained about de
Blasio for the next hour yes he needs to
do something about the roads look I
don't specific
Kyle they might just lightly beat him up
so we could do nothing we could take the
loophole you do love loopholes I know we
just put Sheamus behind us but
unfortunately
you've made me a better person save Kyle
to help Kyle
good
I'm proud of you
oh okay I'm sorry I just said you're
proud of me that's my tear trigger
oh
I paid my debt now if you excuse me you
don't know me anything but I owe you and
what exactly does that mean that means
you mess with my family I mess with
yours tell your husband Kevin I'll see
him real soon what did you just say
is he gonna go support Kevin that's
right he's gonna go invite Kevin to fill
Kyle's place because Kevin is clearly
much more competent okay he's gonna give
him a job it's just the tone sounded
threatening but no it'll be an offer he
can't refuse then he would see him soon
so I was like oh maybe it's not a bad
thing he's gonna walk chattering from
now on
yeah all right yeah yeah everything
worked out in him yeah that's good and
it all made sense with part one I
shouldn't let Kyle die they should have
killed him themselves that would have
just like Kyle Dyke as a he's
gonna die anyway
well he's made it till this point what
if he's one of those people who's like
blessed to to just
fail Perpetual going to do the Godfather
you let Fredo die that's true you got to
that's right I broke the rules I'm sorry
yep Fredo's got to die well I don't know
why this was a two-parter but I'm not
complaining I enjoy both episodes don't
worry but I will complain Danny Trejo's
gonna come and fix this for them later
we'll complain the only two-parter thing
about it is Gina's back
yes did that happen in the first part
yes John of course cyber security that's
right the Cyber guys yeah pay attention
I know what's wrong with you we just
watched it I know this is the most
innocuous details but then fit like that
is kind of wild
um yeah so Gina's back good good
I guess that is the only connective
tissue because like nothing do we even
talk about Rosa being bit no it's the
only connection first one is stronger
sure yeah this one was more like
serially of consequence
but uh yeah the first one was a
character-driven episode yeah that was
good you know with the Rosa having to
come out to her parents and deal with
the
uncomfortableness of that whole thing
which
I
feel like it's so fiction never happens
in real life so it's nice that they can
get some alt Universe take on what
happens in reality which is most parents
are like cool I love it I was hoping you
would say that love to hear it dare tell
me your header because there's too many
of them out here yeah I want you to be
more broad-minded than me yeah no I mean
especially in certain cultures white
cultures I'm talking about white people
love that stuff yeah we love uh only
white people are accepting gay children
every other race is homophobic that's
right just genetically it's not possible
to rise above that stuff
cultures no no no no no I've seen all
kinds I've heard uh actually
my when I was 15. yeah I won't specify
who
there's an incident with my white friend
oh no and the dad said if I ever see
that do that again I'll disown you oh
wow that was like the slightest
slightest thing that wasn't even that
gay I think I know come on it's pretty
obvious if you know our past John yeah
anyway yeah
and actually
pretty accepting yeah
but it doesn't matter people go through
it it obviously happens it's real it
goes denominant in a lot of it there's
every version yeah but a lot of them are
difficult culturally yes yeah
um I was just spouting off there uh but
yeah that was a good performance from
Stephanie Beatrice I can see how she got
Encanto from this
this episode yeah Danny Trejo fresh off
his bankruptcy uh he did a good job he
did a good job he wasn't just very
honest yeah I know he's soft he's a
software here's a nice guy in real life
it seems like a nice guy in real life
yeah but he could have bankrupt just now
something about not paying his taxes oh
good yeah that's a good way to like
eliminate your debt that's why a lot of
celebs sometimes do that they file
bankruptcy
I see okay John just had a light bulb
idea
file for bankruptcy every few years I'm
not gonna rack up all the things I want
in this life yeah
money is of no matter to me
yeah that was nice
what else happened John oh goodness
baggies how about Gina being back I'm
excited but yeah because just in episode
nine we were thinking like yeah she just
gone like what's going on she's still in
the main credits and then yeah she shows
back up nice surprise there nice
sparring with Paul shear and uh and then
you know cresting into the next episode
getting an actual like Gina character
but you know it's like the first brings
back like the funny tough Gina that you
know is like the you know the the
flagship flavor of the character it's
probably not the best way to describe
that but you know the defining
characteristic but then this episode you
see that yes indeed she is responding to
the needs and demands of motherhood like
a human person a little overwhelmed and
I like getting both it really is the
only way these two episodes connect is
you get these two complementary sides of
Gina in a nice way and uh and yeah you
get her paired off at least with a
couple other characters who you're not
usually pairing her off with which is
nice
back and forth between two parents Gina
and Terry yeah and and uh this we
thought we would wrap up the Sheamus
thing but apparently not fools I like
the guy played Kyle he was hilarious
he's really Earnest and sincere and
genuine and something else authentic
yeah yes very a little foreign
yeah I wonder who that guy is because uh
you know this is something he's like
they the the look they gave him the fact
that he's a rapper he struck me kind of
like an action Bronson type but I I
don't think that's him uh but either way
whoever this guy is I assume he's
probably like a comedian or something uh
yeah he had a he had a very fun bro I
really enjoyed watching them like bounce
around with him and the idea that he
might come back you know because they're
doing this protective custody thing like
I'm looking forward to that I think
that'd be very fun that was man
yeah and I mean I thought they did a
nice job of making it so close you know
it's like oh man this is the perfect you
can get in and get out without even
being detected but then uh you know
shame is too smart too Wily
they would have been held responsible
and the day it would have been held
responsible yeah there's no way this was
going to end right here it wouldn't be
dramatically Hefty enough it would have
been a morally bad decision to let
colleges die yeah absolutely it doesn't
deserve that whatsoever because Kyle was
out and then they pulled him back in and
he's not got an evil bone in his body
now Rosa and Amy together doing the
permits that was fun
the best part is that's part of this
whole thing that's why we saved it for
last because it left the biggest
impression so and then we're gonna do
this game night every week half anything
I'm gonna see this game night this is
the only time that's what I'm thinking
yes driver's gonna forget all about this
it's a very sweet lovely gesture and uh
and then yeah it'll come back when we
need another guest star or something to
reveal who her girlfriend is yeah uh
I mean yeah like like that subplot of
her being bi we'll come back sooner than
game nights of any variety I think we'll
come back true true true
um but yeah it was nice it was good uh
good return for Gina some good event
stories and what not a good like
contrast a very special episode and then
you know
I mean the last one's called Game Night
part one right I think so
they had two different titles though I'm
pretty sure yeah the favor and then game
night is there a game night part two
coming up nope I guess it is just I mean
unless unless it's only part one and two
because they aired the same day or
something like that is like all I can
they did yeah because like yeah oh yeah
oh it was one of those things Brooklyn
has that thing where it's like they have
like Hey we're gonna be gone for like
six to eight months yeah we're taking
like a Hiatus so uh We've we've got this
yeah like one hour event
um but I don't know yeah it says part
one of two and part two of them yeah
yeah no like I mean look at this there's
a long break
yeah this is weird I guess yeah just to
get the pre it's the part one and two of
getting the entire Precinct back
together
well I enjoyed it guys what did you
think about these two pars which one did
you prefer did you have to come out to
your parents uh leave your thoughts down
below
uh you can subscribe leave a like before
we go let's end this with a patreon
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia about her if
there's anything I know it's that Delia
would run the most smooth and efficient
forms and stuff yeah if she had to like
be in charge of a bunch of forms like
the overarching bureaucracy of an
organization sounds realistic I would
freaking trust Adelia with that like
you know because I feel like you could
probably cut out a lot of the nonsense
so many of these systems you can make
things streamlined clear easy to
understand but also yeah and you know
capable of getting the job done with
minimal headaches think of all the
different government
institutions you could revolutionize
Adelia you know how to compliment I do I
do you no one's better at paperwork than
you but Adelia you're also a sweet and
lovely and kind human being and the kind
of person who would not let someone like
uh the Kyle character just if we were in
trouble because you involved Us in some
kind of form related maneuver and we've
got pinned for it you wouldn't just let
us rot you would come and set things
right because that's who you are I can
totally see you being so good at
paperwork that you could file a
complaint to HR about John sexually
harassing you and it would be heard
I bet she did that's probably a true
assessment yeah regardless of the facts
of the matter I'm sure you could get
that job done no matter what office
space you're in you're gonna be getting
hit on left and right hey hey
that's you that's you a deal here how's
it going twitch you're a hot pair of
Pancakes
yes a pair of Pancakes that's how I like
my stacks just two
just two
you're you're and and yeah you're like
endless endless pancakes yeah you're the
joy of endless pancakes
they pledged hopefully someday we'll
share common space again
[Applause]